hi my name is chef lawrence page and
today we're going to be making delicious
homemade mac and cheese
mac and cheese growing up in my house
was really unique because you know we
couldn't afford a lot of different
cheeses like we do today like feta
cheese and smoked gouda and things like
that you know we always stuck with just
the cheddar cheese and the mozzarella
but my mom always made the best mac and
cheese i always licked the bowl when she
was done even before the mac and cheese
was cooked so i knew exactly what that
taste was and it lives with me today my
mother taught me how to cook as a little
boy growing up in the house i've always
was intrigued with all his dishes and
all his food on thanksgiving laid around
and how was she gonna cook all of this
stuff with no sous chef no dishwasher
you know what i mean so i watch
everything that she did then that's when
i started questioning her like how do i
cook that how do i cook this and she
basically told me that you grew up with
soul so it's in you so just figure it
out
soul food is one of those type of things
that brings a lot of families together
when we grow up especially as being
black we feel that we've been eating
this food all our lives and it's a
conversational piece because you know
who made the ham today who made the mac
and cheese who made the collard greens
there's always a story behind who made
what when it comes to soul food auntie
june make the best sweet potatoes uncle
earl makes the best fried chicken is he
making his fried chicken this year and i
think that's what makes soul food
because we all have stories and we
remember growing up who made what dish
in the house and how it made us feel and
we could all have our differences in
life you know but when we come together
at the table one thing bring us together
is that soul food
you